Leon Weinberg is the name I was born and
Poland in 1925 that made me I was 13
years old when the war broke out well my
life in Poland before the war was I
guess was as normal as anybody could
picture a young Jewish boy from a
middle-income family growing up in big
city I was born in a lodge which was one
of the biggest city in in Poland I went
to a Hebrew school which is a not a
seder Hebrew school and when the war
broke out I was just about finished with
my public Hebrew school and ready to go
on to gymnasium which is high school as
I'm sure you know my family was my
father mother and all the sister and a
younger sister plus a very large larger
family like aunts uncles which I I would
guess a month ago but maybe 200 people
or maybe more and the happy memories
there was some school kids I was
involved in a lot of sports activities
belonging to a sports club and playing
table tennis soccer like any other
normal I would say teenager and I
remember exactly that day when the
Polish army was leaving the city and the
following day the Germans
often marched in you know I in fact at
that time as kids we stood on the
streets we watched them come in not
knowing what to expect and they looked
to me like like woman gladiators with
with the Panther trucks with what that
tanks marching to the city but it wasn't
it wasn't fair that time it was just
uncertainty we didn't know what to
expect and it was always that feeling
God will give something will happen well
nothing wrong with not nothing's gonna
happen to us and just the first few days
of them in the city of bright come from
a lodge we're just about quiet well we
found out that the ghetto is going to be
formed in the city of lunch which was
that time the name was changed till it's
mon stopped the german name for lunch we
were few the lucky ones because the part
of the tower i lived in was so it was
going to be the part of the ghetto so we
didn't have to leave our apartment so we
just stayed where we had own thing we
had to congest a little bit because in
about one week that whole part of town
swelled from a population that part of
the city from a population of probably
maybe forty or fifty thousand people to
about three hundred thousand and plus
every day all night people were brought
in from the outskirts of lodge two to
know exactly how many people the way I
don't remember they would slap the
little wagons
too we are against what all the
belonging whatever they could save and
how they settle them what happened to
them I I don't even know I know that
they slept and schools and factories
whatever liquid they could push you
and that's where the life in ghetto
started well I spent I spent four years
in the lodger ghetto and the only way
then out was only for official people
bringing in the little food we used to
get from the outside and took a few more
just a few months and we were organized
and a little small self ruling
government with Jewish policemen Jewish
president it was it was a a government
run by Jews but naturally overlooked by
the Germans they form the government of
of Jews and the head of the government
was they call them his name was Gugu
makovski he happened to be a a before
the war as I as I was told I never knew
of him we worked in factories producing
clothing for the German army his shoes
for them food was given to you by racing
cars naturally and naturally the food
ration started to get smaller and
smaller
now I don't know if I could ever
thinking back what the type of or the
amount of food we are getting was
unthinkable of now because they got to a
point and today through the a year later
where we would live on about eight
ounces of bread a day there was no
butter was margarine and a couple ounces
of sugar like meat maybe couple ounces a
medium a month it was starvation they
got to I think in 1940 and the logic get
though people were dying at the weight I
don't have the exact figures but there
was no more the the one no more funerals
at the beginning we had a funeral if
someone died there was a real Jewish
funeral but I got to a point afterwards
where people were taking away and the
and the funeral cards with the horse and
wagon naturally ten twelve and one in
one wagon piled up on top at that time I
the only thought in them days was hunger
you woke up in the morning hungry and
you went to sleep hungry now I don't
know too many people realize that when
you were hungry there was nothing else
in the world which matters I was hungry
for four years I never had my belly full
in four years I don't think any thought
there's nothing else when you're hungry
you you it gets to a point where you
don't mind stealing from your own sister
from your own father
there were there were families could be
friends of mine ourselves where
everybody would get their ration of
bread now this is how people are get to
be after after being hungry and being
now they say they're being degraded
brought to a point where they have no
more self-respect I would get up in the
middle of night and slice a piece of
bread off my sister's eration
now I you would never picture me and I
can't even imagine myself doing that now
but that happened parents my parents
will never do that to me but as kids we
would try to steal still in a way of not
thinking the hammer will do
but I don't know I don't even remember
the feeling it was just that there was
just nothing else in your mind is but
hungry now III often thought that this
gotta be a way of really getting people
to hate each other breaking up families
or breaking up of breaking down the
morale of people with not feeling them
and no matter what we try to do it was
always one thought going home hungry
going out getting up in the morning
hungry and it's fine you know I can't
even think that's the only thing I hear
do you think of us as food well I stayed
in the ghetto like I was saying the the
the the labor camp started coming in the
labor commandos I did all kind of work
in there yet though I was working at and
and on buildings I was working as a as a
taking buildings down I was working
cleaning out toilets I was working you
name it I did any kind of work and for
some reason I was left in the ghetto I
guess I was lucky at that point though
because I'm still alive now until 1944
at that time there were camps already
we didn't fact when people were going
out out of the ghetto with transport
like thousand or 2,000 people at a time
and that was that probably was the worst
the worst pay of my life is the way we
were taking out of the ghetto to work
the way it happened it would happen any
time in a day the middle of the night or
in the daytime and the Thunder commander
what they called Gestapo would come in
few officers with a couple of dogs and
they would come in Europe as you know
the courtyards they will come in the
courtyard and blow the whistle and
everyone in that house in that apartment
has to come down to the to the to the
eye and that would be a selection then
and naturally everyone I remember my
mother she put a lot of makeup on
herself to make yourself look good young
because they would pick people you never
knew who they're gonna pick if the young
ones the good-looking ones the healthy
wants to the sick ones so you just took
a chance and they would just pick and
every day they would pick a few people
on the truck and they will disappear
never heard of them never knew what
happened Wilmes where they were taking
to you that Treblinka oh we didn't know
about oestrus I myself didn't know the
first thing about Auschwitz Thanks I
didn't knew nothing what was going on
outside of the ghetto no news could come
in to the ghetto to go on of everyday
life in the ghetto it would be I
probably could stay here for 24 hours
and about little incidents what's what
what happening but they get the life was
the only with all the hungry I was
saying all the hunger and all the the
the the you know stealing because
stealing was the this to survive you had
to steal it got to a point like I said
you have to steal from your own and not
you're not thinking you're doing wrong
because you always made excuses or maybe
I'm young I I you know it won't hurt my
parents if I steal a piece of bread from
them and after a while you know it got
they got even it bothered you and and
plane times I would just say it wasn't
to a point where I would hurt them I
don't mean I stole from them that I and
I you know I made him starve but it's I
thought that a slice of bread or slice
of brother would want to hurt them but
it make me feel better you asked me how
it happened now I couldn't not I
couldn't honestly say why I did it
though I love my parents and I and I
probably just a thought that they
haven't gone disappear or die or be
killed
scared me anytime where the Gestapo
would come and pick people I've always
hoped nobody I hope nobody for my family
will be taking away
and for some reason until 1944 we
escaped every I'll see long they called
it in fact I was the first one to be
taken away from my family when I left
the ghetto the way it happened in fact
let me check back in 1942 was the worst
time in the ghetto as far as I'll see
long at that time we had a Children's
Hospital and across the street from us
away led and I seen young infants just
born being torn out of the windows and
trucks and every morning you find out
this one was taken away this one left to
get though not left I mean was taking
away this one died and the family I've
had that and he was a big family a lot
of uncles and aunts and cousins it was
getting smaller and smaller
in 1944 I think it wasn't much it was a
knock at our door they came looking for
me why it was just picked at random I
was still young healthy to be taken to a
labor camp and that's the last time I
seen my parents and my my sisters I was
scared but never thought of being killed
off I until that time I I did not know
about any a crematoriums I didn't know
about Auschwitz I didn't know I was
taking with a group of about I think was
700 people to to the town of Chester
house which was about oh I would say
about
seventy miles away from lodge and there
I was put to work and they building a
German Factory
the German evacuated that whole Factory
naturally with us and we were put all of
us there was that group I was with was
about 350 we were put on a cattle train
and sent to Germany now that must have
been probably the worst trip in my life
or the worst experience I've ever had we
spent seven days and seven nights in a
cattle train there was 80 people in one
and one and one
wagon we took out at least ten guys dead
in that seven days travelling we stopped
we went from Chester hop on the whole
trip didn't take that long but we were
left on the railway tracks on the side
tracks for all days they were just
pushing us back and forth and seven days
later we arrived and book about all we
could see is from the little windows
look out there standing up no out to
relieve yourself everything had to be
done right there on the top of one each
other when we slept
we had to somehow squeeze in standing up
laying down or just leaning on top of
each other now that's got to be think of
it I don't it was a nightmare when we
got to book about it was it was the end
of 1944 I spend I spend about two months
and book about itself and then the same
people who came from that factory and
chance to how that all of us a350 was
whatever was left from that group were
taking into a small town by book Hobart
was called Sonnenberg where we were put
to work in a factory but the same factor
which we were building and back Paulin
there were quite a few deaths every day
because of starvation of beatings and
the only hope we had then we started
hearing rumors about the wall being
close to an end
that was that was already in 1945 to
begin 1945 but after five years from 13
i toll and we didn't believe any rumors
because we had rumors all along that the
wars only gonna last for one day two day
two days one month two months three
months a year two years and then it
dragged on so at that time that was just
no no no hope when we were taken to
Sonnenberg in that in that factory we
had we worked there for about two months
and then we're the worst probably period
of our life started what they called a
March in April of 1945 we knew that
something is happening with the wall
because we seen the first signs of of
the war coming to an end we went on a
March took us seven days we slept in the
open rainin and and and the time it was
we had a lot of rain in them and in that
part of the country we slept and one one
night I remember they put us in and a
schoolroom where they blacked off half
of the room they put 300 people in a
room about the size maybe twice of here
we slept on top of each other all night
and if anyone stuck his head out there
was a German there were they with a whip
and he would hit us in the head then the
following night we slept in a barn where
a friend of mine sticking his friend on
my say I fell I wasn't camper at that
time I don't even remember his name now
stuck his head out and he was shot right
there
we had to start out again and from
we marched again for two weeks not to
describe that March is really it's it's
it's it's impossible
we have met naturally we didn't take our
clothes off we marched we march we march
for two weeks from one village into the
other and then the we started out there
was 350 laughs when we got where we
liberated in fact when we liberated
there was 200 of us left it was 150
killed or died on that March I had I was
with a friend of mine who was a very
good friend of mine since childhood we
went camp together he was very sick and
I guess I saved his life by he was ready
to commit suicide and I dragged them
with somebody else's help
and somehow the wall and that you we
liberated I saved them but while at that
March which lasted for about three or
three and a half weeks we had one we had
one incident going away to a a through
woods it says 11 kilometers on it
and that lieutenant Howard out loud he
says if you don't hurry up the last one
gets shot every kilometer and sure he
did that we didn't know where we go we
went from one village into the other we
just just liked like like a
merry-go-round and before we know I your
shots and screaming and before we know
the soldiers the Germans have taken
their hands up and that's how we and I
see this some American a couple tanks
one truck few American soldiers that's
how we were liberated you know just a
turn happened just like that I thought
that the joy would be tremendous it
wasn't it was just just taking and first
thing was just get something to eat was
a bread or whatever and you know such a
long time but I I don't think I was
happy I didn't dance from Joe
I think we just I don't think we had any
feelings for then single or joy or
smiling anything with just a very very
it was an existence that's all it was it
wasn't I think I could be happy I don't
think I realized what happened to me
until I don't think I've ever I don't
think I've ever because too many things
happened afterwards you know finding out
that my family's all gone
Oh getting used to what things where I
don't think I've ever been very
overjoyed that I stayed alive at that
time anyway it was just
either way it happened happen I had I
had a lot I had that I had very bad
nightmares right after the war where I
what happened after the war when I was
liberated I went back to Poland to look
for my family so I didn't stay on in
Germany I took the first train back and
I went back to my hometown to my old
apartment to my old house and naturally
that was my I broke down completely
that's about the only time I broken down
there was after right after the wall and
I spent a little time there waiting for
someone to show up I thought maybe the
someone's still alive
I spent about four or five months and
afterward Poland and then I went back to
Germany and then living in the DP camps
for about three years there was a period
of life where everything just we tried
to block everything out of mind it was
just an unnatural existence like I've
lived probably a double a life before
and a life now which is something that
the entire love different what we have
now another thing I can never forget
that I don't think I can ever I did try
the first years you know after after the
war
I think I did try to erase everything
during the war and I fact I don't think
I would have a sit-down talk about it if
you asked me that but see I came here in
1949 30 years ago if you had approached
me I wouldn't I don't think I would have
and my memories were much fresher than
but I absolutely would not talk about it
but then later on I just started feeling
different I started to to look back and
seeing that things cannot be forgotten
that you can't just walk away from it or
you can't just say this is it I can't
don't talk about it in fact I was I was
ashamed to talk about it I almost
started someone like you said ah we
don't want to listen about it we don't
want to hear about it we know all we
have to know about it but it's not like
that I think I think about it more now
maybe because I get all day and I'm
getting mellow to say I think a lot
about it too much I think
you